bonsoir
les anciens ce sont les grès
j'étais juste pour préciser
alors pourquoi cette question
pour illustrer la fragilité des
connaissances humaines et pour servir de
mise en garde
on vit dans un âge d'or technique à
chaque année et des produits plus
performants plus sophistiqués qui sont
mis sur le marché
l'industrie humaine a tant bien que mal
réussi et nourrir plus de 7 milliards
d'individus les famines des siècles
passés sont très mauvais souvenir et
parallèlement un sens les connaissances
les plus poussées dans tous les domaines
nous sont offertes la plupart du temps
gratuitement il suffit de quelques clics
sur internet pour les cueillir et
pourtant tout ça est fragile tout ça
pourrait disparaître et pourquoi je dis
ça parce que c'est déjà arrivé
ce qui est illustré ici on appelle ça la
machine d'anticythère
au fond c'est ce qui est en bas ça c'est
une reconstitution de la machine
d'anticythère ça a été découvert dans
une épave
romaine dont s'était découvert vers 1900
dans une épave romaine qui datent du
premier siècle avant notre ère
et ça a pris bon bout de temps tu depuis
seulement les années 2000 on a réussi à
comprendre ce que c'est savoir ce que
c'est parce qu'on a les techniques
d'imagerie plus sophistiqués rayons x et
celle à qui on s'est rendu compte que
c'est en fait un calculateur
astronomique
fait de dizaines d' engrenage en bronze
et qui réussit à prédire les éclipses de
soleil les phases la lune le mouvement
des planètes et ainsi de suite avant il
ya quelques années on n'avait aucune
idée que les grecs de l'antiquité était
capable de construire un dispositif
comme celui ci
une autre preuve des prouesses
techniques des anciens c'est dans les
constructions la perfection des
constructions ce que vous allez ici
c'est le pont du gard c'est une partie
de l'aqueduc de nîmes en plus de la
france et c'est à queue du cac
affichait une dénivellation une pente de
25 cm par km sur 50 km de long
remarquable et parallèlement à ses
prouesses techniques il y avait des
connaissances des connaissances
scientifiques
disons entre autres qui à la différence
près que ces connaissances là ont eu
leur apogée si on veut donc l'âge d'or
de la c1 30,6 et entre 300 ans avant
notre ère et 150 avant notre ère
il semble qu'après cette époque il y a
eu une espèce de non pas de bouille de
décadence disons que la science cessé de
progresser c'est figé dans un état peut
être sous standard et finalement avec la
décadence de l'empiré romain et bien les
livres des manuscrits c'est à dire on
ont disparu de plus en plus à quelques
trucs qui ont été recopiées et c'est ce
qui est parvenu jusqu'à nous c'est ce
qu'on en sait
donc vous rendre compte que la copie
avant les prix mais la copie est un
élément essentiel de la transmission du
savoir
j'en prends comme exemple
l'oeuvre la plus connue de la science
antique c'est à dire les éléments de
géométrie les éléments d'euclide
ce livre là
est peut-être le plus anciens manuels
scientifique connu ça même servi de
manuels scolaires jusqu'au 19ème siècle
c'est le livre le plus édités après la
bible depuis l'invention de l'imprimerie
ya plus de 1000 édition des éléments de
clean
et pourtant toutes les éditions viennent
d'un manuscrit qui date d'à peu près 900
de notre ère
ce manuscrit là est le plus ancien connu
qui contient tous les éléments il ya un
fragment de manuscrit
papyrus qui datent du premier siècle de
notre ère une proposition est pourtant
un clip vivait 300 ans avant notre ère
et la plupart des propositions des
théorèmes dans son oeuvre était connu
avant jusqu'à l'époque de pythagore 200
ans avant donc on voit le fils très ténu
des connaissances qui vient de 500 ans
avant notre ère en passant par un
manuscrit jusqu'à nos jours
beaucoup d oeuvre de l'antiquité étaient
en fait des catalogues ou enfin
comporter des catalogues d'autres
oeuvres des bibliographies sion et c'est
avec ça qu'on mesure un peu les pertes
c'est à dire des oeuvres dont on sait
qu'elles existent mais qu'on n'a pas
l'une des oeuvres les compenser perdu du
grand archimède archimaine c'était le
plus grand des ingénieurs de l'antiquité
dit-on bien le des oeuvres les plus
connues d'archimède s'appelle la méthode
au boulon dans ce livre il explique une
technique mathématique qui préfigure le
calcul intégral comment calculer le
volume d'une sphère comment calculer le
volume de l'hémisphère et ainsi de suite
on croyait cette oeuvre perdu à jamais
jusqu'en 1906 ou savants danois a trouvé
ceci
quelque part à constantinople et on a
passé un palimpseste qui peu long
compliqué un palimpseste ces
manuscrits qui a été recyclé c'est à
dire c'est du parchemin et la peau d'un
animal qui a été effacé gratter pour
faire place à quelque chose d'autre donc
dans cette illustration qui est qui
commandait enrichie par une lumière tu
lis et là on a deux livres 1 qui est
écrit horizontalement qui est écrit
verticalement encore le plus parlant
entre les deux c'est le livre
d'archimède
l'original donc le premier parchemin été
copiés au 10ème siècle de notre ère il a
été effacé trois cents ans plus tard
pour être remplacé par un livre de
prières
et donc ça c'est le sort qu'ont réservé
au chef d'oeuvre de l'antiquité
l'une des idées
reçues de nos jours c'est que les gens
du moyen âge mais l'antiquité penser que
la terre était plate
il ya des gens au 21ème siècle qui
pensent que la terre est plate mais au
moyen âge les gens instruits savait que
la terre est testé riscle dans
l'antiquité aussi il ya un grand savant
d'antiquités qui s'appelait eratosthène
qui vivait au 3e siècle avant notre ère
qui avec calculée et mesurée que la
circonférence de la terre était de 250
2000 stade égyptien ce qui correspond à
la valeur réelle à 1 ou 2% après c'est
l'erreur de cette estimation là est
l'erreur vient surtout du fait qu'on
sait pas avec une très grande précision
ce que vos stades égyptien
mais toute son oeuvre c'est un immense
livre le livre d'eratosthène on l'a pas
le livre i perdu tout ce qu'on connaît
de lui c'est par citation dans un autre
auteur dans un autre livre plus tardif
et c'est comme ça avec beaucoup de
grandes oeuvres scientifique de
l'antiquité
une autre idée préconçue plus dans le
domaine économique celle-là c'est que
les anciens ne connaissait pas le
principe d'inertie c'est à dire bon f
également les lois de newton la
mécanique quand elle ne connaissait pas
non plus la gravitation universelle
c'est ce qu'on a mais généralement en
fait la vision qu'on a de la science
antique celle qui a été transmise le
plus souvent c'est un système du cosmos
où les différentes planètes les astres
sont fichés sur des sphères où des
cercles qui sont imbriqués les uns dans
les autres qui tourne de manière
régulière un système
géocentrique avec la terre au centre et
vous n'y a pas vraiment de cause il n'y
a qu'une description mathématiques du
mouvement or
certains indices nous permettent de
douter de cela et ça vient pas des
livres des grands scientifiques de
l'antiquité qui sont la plupart perdu ça
vient de sources secondaires par la
bande c'est à dire des citations qui
sont dans d'autres oeuvres
plus tardive par des auteurs qui ne sont
pas des scientifiques eux mêmes c'est du
ouï-dire en quelque sorte et je vais
vous en citer trois je vais commencer
par plutarque plus tard c'est celui qui
a écrit les vies parallèles des grecs et
des romains c'est un historien célèbre
du vivaient environ 150 de notre ère
et dans un de ses ouvrages mineurs moins
connus où il parle du mouvement de la
lune et il dit toutefois ce qui est de
la lune à ne pas tomber sur la terre
c'est ça marche même et la rapidité de
sa révolution ainsi les projectiles
placé sur une fronde se trouvent retenus
par le mouvement circulaire qui devrait
imprimer chaque corps en effet suis sous
l'impulsion naturel à moins d'en être
détournée par une autre voilà pourquoi
la lune ne cède pas à l'entraînement de
sa pesanteur parce que cette pesanteur
même est neutralisée par la rapidité de
ces révolutions donc pour ceux qui ont
fait un peu de physique et de mécanique
c'est la force centrifuge la force
centrifuge qui contrebalance
l'attraction de la terre et de la lune
c'est c'est tout à fait moderne comme
affirmation et c'est pas du tout en
ligne avec ce que l'on sait de la
science antique l'habituellement c'est
donc étrange même venant de quelqu'un
qui était comme plutarque cultivé mais
non pas scientifique lui-même
autre citation sénèque premiers siècles
de notre ère
si les planètes s'arrêtait cela signifie
que ces scores qui sont en mouvement
constant et équilibrée tomberait les uns
sur les autres
c'est très gravitation universelle n'est
ce pas des planets attire les unes les
autres
vitruve qui est un architecte romain
premier siècle avant notre ère la
puissante force du soleil étant dans ses
rayons comme un triangle attire vers lui
les planètes et empêchent leur mouvement
vers l'avant et les force à revenir vers
lui donc ça aussi c'est
étrangement moderne comme affirmation
contraire à la description naïve qu'on a
des mouvements des astres surtout qu'ici
le soleil est au centre
et en passant la citation de plus tard
de tout à l'heure newton la connaissait
newton la cité dans une des oeuvres de
jeunesse qui n'a pas été publié donc il
y à un fil conducteur entre la science
de l'antiquité la science moderne la
science moderne n'est pas né au xviie
siècle les ressusciter ou xviie siècle à
partir de une survivance de la science
antique section senti qu il a connu son
âge d'or comme je le disais entre 350
mots notre ère alexandrie était de
centre alexandrie a été fondée par
alexandre le grand en 331 avant notre
ère ensuite l'egypte est devenue royaume
avec des rois grecque la plupart
s'appelait tollé mais de 1 jusqu'à 15 je
crois qu'il faut comme ça et une
cléopâtre aussi est plutôt les mets 2 a
fondé le musée d'alexandrie musée au
sens de temples des muses c'était comme
l'université de l'époque donc on y
enseignait la littérature la physique
les mathématiques la médecine la
philosophie et ses suites
et
alexandrie c'était pas le centre
exclusif y avait aussi des grands
savants ailleurs l'oncle archimède dont
j'ai parlé était à syracuse en sicile
mais le point commun c'est qu'ils
étaient tous grecs
se fait notable qu on ne connaît on peut
pas nommer un seul
mathématicien romains de l'époque romane
oui mais des grecs pas de romain
alors comment ce que tout ça a disparu
difficile à dire il ya des facteurs qui
n'ont pas aidé il ya eu une guerre
civile en egypte ou dans le temps du roi
ptolémée 8 et les savants grec où la
communauté grec d'alexandrie a choisi le
mauvais côté en fait le mauvais bord de
la guerre civile il ya une purge après
et puis cette communauté qui était le
ferment du développement de la science a
été détruite mais la raison de fond
probablement c'est que les romains il
remet ont pris possession du bassin
méditerranéen à partir du 1er siècle
avant notre ère ont utilisé les
connaissances des grecs c'est un peuple
très pratique il voulait appliquer ces
connaissances là mais n'était pas
tellement intéressé à les développer ses
connaissances pur et donc la science a
stagné et puis l'empiré romain
entraînant des cadences probablement que
la plupart des gens l'époque sommes très
peu de personnes probablement réalisé
que l'empiré et est en décadence quand
il était et le fil en aiguille ces
choses ont disparu les manuscrits n'ont
pas été recopiées seuls les trucs les
plus populaires l'ont été et voilà ça
donnait le moins large et ça donnait une
science qui a failli mourir mais qui
ressuscite et quand même
alors est ce que la science moderne est
menacée d'un oubli sans blâme
pas pour le moment parce que là jamais
été aussi bien diffusée dans l'histoire
et l'histoire malheureusement la
fâcheuse tendance à se répéter merci
[Applaudissements]